do you think Kanye is using the black  community right now oh of course he uses  black people like Buddha side chick you  get what I mean yes yo the side should  get more attention when you and your  main chick beefing you decides to get  more attention when you and your main  girl has like an off week or y'all break  up for a while or when you're you know  there's there's certain side chicks that  even when you're single you're still a  side chick so even when he has he's he  got nobody you're still the side chick  so what you decide so you can feel a  little bit more special well I can sleep  tonight  but I don't even think it's about money  necessarily for yay yeah I think it's  about complete control yeah and he's  control the rap already he's like all  right we make some shirts with some  holes in there it's fire don't so let me  do this it's fire torso don't you now  let me go go higher you know what I mean